[Music]
it's official the Rosanne spin-off is
headed to TV without Roseanne on
Thursday ABC formally announced a
10-episode order for the new series set
to premiere this fall tentatively titled
the Connors it'll feature much of the
original cast - the title character who
sparked a scandal last month after
posting a racist tweet about former
White House adviser Valerie Jarrett
after the spin-off news broke Roseann
released a statement to ET she said
quote I regret the circumstances that
have caused me to be removed from
Roseanne I agreed to the settlement in
order that 200 jobs of beloved cast and
crew could be saved and I wish the best
for everyone involved with Roseanne gone
from the spinoff
fans are speculating how her absence
will be addressed
according to ABC's official statement it
seems like her character could be killed
off quote after a sudden turn of events
the Conners are forced to face the daily
struggles of life in Lanford in a way
they never have before
[Music]
[Applause]